it's the match we've all been waiting
for the final european championship
match between eures
and the challenges the teams are on
their way to play the biggest football
match in europe for the freedom of
movement of workers
the challenges team have a new star
player kovind 19
but eures have brought in new players to
deal with this threat
on the euros side we have the ronaldo
eures portal
neuaya eures advisors the ramos eures
language courses
and the new eures striker levanovsky
working from home
meanwhile on the challenges team the
evil language barriers
the revenge administrative burdens and
of course their new star striker
the joker kovid19
the challenges are off to a great start
it's a long ball from revenge
administrative burdens to joker kobit
19.
kovi 19 has the ball in front of the
goal shoot
oh what a save from naya ura's advisors
eures ramos language courses now has the
ball and dribbles past the evil language
barriers
spectacular passes by the euros team the
ronaldo euros portal takes a shot and
go victory for eures helping another
candidate land their job abroad and
keeping the free movement of workers
flowing across europe despite the
pandemic
go uras